Ucrania cumple esta semana un año de esa
invasión de Gran escala lanzada el
pasado 24 de febrero de 2022 y en el
terreno estamos viendo cómo ha cambiado
el rostro de este país en este tiempo
muchísimas familias empiezan a tener
amigos y familiares que han fallecido en
particular soldados aquí en el pueblo
donde nos encontramos los vecinos han
colocado una placa en honor a un soldado
fallecido en el sur de Ucrania hace
pocos meses y también es visible ese
desplazamiento de personas de otras
regiones ucranianas que se encuentran
más cercanas al frente de batalla hacia
el este donde estamos ahora precisamente
solo en la ciudad de libido hay 125 mil
desplazados internos y también se han
mudado muchísimas empresas que para
seguir
bueno para seguir produciendo
precisamente han trasladado sus oficinas
a esta zona del país y en este contexto
la guerra se encuentra en este momento
en un momento delicado Ucrania sigue
pidiendo el envío en particular de
municiones pero los socios occidentales
los aliados europeos y estadounidenses
están empezando a manifestar
dificultades para cumplir con las
necesidades ucranianas en este sentido
Será muy importante escuchar las
palabras del presidente estadounidense
Joe biden que los próximos días tiene
previsto un viaje a Polonia donde se
espera que informe sobre la línea de
Washington en las próximas semanas y
meses